my sister knows me
she is the one that was there through my SuperWhoLock phase
through my emo phase
through my one direction phase
and now you know
10 years later
she's the one who's here post college
like watching me become a person
and I'm doing the same with her
like my little sister is the valedictorian of CAS NYU right now
and we just had this conversation about how like
her friends from college
like they know her now
but they didn't know her when she was in high school
and her friends in high school
they don't really know fully who she is now
and we were like
we know each other
we're the only ones that are gonna always know each other
because we are the only ones that are gonna be in our lives forever
you know
I have immigrant parents and they really stressed family when I was growing up
and me and my sister weren't always the best of friends
we're always friends
but not not the way we are now
and now we're roommates
like she is the most important person in my life
hands down I would do anything for her
I love her so much
my parents really stress like friends
they come and go
but like your family
your sister is going to be the person at your side at all times and
I love her so much